the tourist traffic continues off North
America's Coast these work whale
watchers leaving Boston the benign end
of Atlantic attractions
Adventures Other Extreme had occupied
this City's Coast Guard this week
there was no news today for them to
report the day before had drawn a line
under their hunt and hope for a
submersible missing at sea
this is video from 2021 of the Titan
submersible with a guided tour from the
man behind it two years after these
pictures were filmed Stockton Rush would
be among the five who died on board and
all the lead down here can be dropped in
an absolute emergency so you can get to
the surface amidst questions over safety
his words then have a dark Echo no I'd
like to be remembered as an innovator
um I think it was General MacArthur said
you remembered for the rules you break
and you know I've broken some rules to
make this there has been criticism of
the man who built the Titan and its
carbon fiber designs but there is also
support from a co-founder of his company
he was a talented engineer who's very
intelligent person who's a passionate
Explorer but mostly he was a keen risk
manager he was very well aware of the
risks of operating at these deep depths
and he was very committed to safety U.S
Navy listening gear underneath the waves
picked up the sound of an implosion as
the Titan made its descent towards the
Titanic there will be investigations
into exactly what happened how and why
for now we're learning more about who
was on board the five who perished
nineteen-year-old Suleiman dawood died
with his father on board the Titan his
aunt said the student had been scared of
the trip but didn't want to disappoint
his father shazada on a Father's Day
weekend
the British billionaire Hamish Harding
was described by his family as a boy who
grew to be a dedicated father a man who
lived for his next adventure pull on
re-nauseally the French navy veteran on
board was remembered by his stepson
Fearless
um this is warm uh bursts of energy I
always got from being with him he's this
incredible human being I mean we can you
know talk forever about his impact in
the ocean but for me the impact was
mostly felt out of the ocean out at Sea
this was the Odyssey 6K one of the
remotely operated vehicles that
discovered debris from the Titan
submersible that search is continuing
Canada's Transportation safety board has
launched an investigation
this was the scene at Newfoundland in
Canada from where the submersible set
sail towards the site with a Titanic
sank in 1912. on the North Atlantic
Shore they honor the victims of the
disaster that followed disaster James
Matthews Sky News in Boston